will snub ignited a really heated debate
and when his wife Jada posted a
heartfelt message that she would not
attend this year's Oscars well an
inferno erupted but here's the thing
will had no idea that Jada was the one
striking the match it's a systematic
bias that needs to be addressed across
the industry there's a disharmony that
is brewing in our country and in our
industry that you know I want I want no
part of that will smith was clear he's
not going to the Oscars this year today
he added his voice to a powerful
diversity discussion his wife started on
facebook I will not be at the Academy
Awards and I won't be watching Jada so
passionate were you aware that she was
going to do that uh no I was uh I was
out of the country at the time and I
came home also today Oscar winner reese
witherspoon called for change posting
quote as an academy member i would love
to see a more diverse voting membership
the Academy says it's listening and
there will be changes on Tuesday at a
regularly scheduled meeting the
Academy's 51 member governing board is
expected to discuss various proposals
among them the membership process and
recruitment how many black films are
being produced every year two-time Oscar
nominee Viola Davis with Nichelle last
night the problem is not with the Oscars
a problem is with the Hollywood movie
making system I mean I think we deserve
a Best Picture I got some nough said Ice
Cube slammed the Academy after straight
out of Compton snub maybe we should have
put a slavish bad I think that's wrong
Wow just one random / 1 rented space
Academy members to recognize us as a
real black
you